at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking good oils you can support now is
the cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by EXO protein that's EXO
like the exoskeleton in aliens and they
make the only bars meal replacement bars
or pre-workout bars in my case that I
have in my house you can hear the
crinkling of cocoa nuts which I'm going
to get back to they're making protein
bars using cricket protein powder and
many of the CrossFit mutants and high
performance out there are eating these
I am also eating them generally
pre-workout and I bet they taste better
than any protein bar you've ever had and
why is that just one of the benefits
while they are exceptionally high in
complete protein they are minimally
processed much less processed than most
say whey protein isolate and packed full
of nutrients including calcium omega-3s
and so on for those people who are
interested also very sustainable so this
is part of the reason I ended up
investing in the company the United
Nations estimates that crickets are 20
times more resource efficient per pound
of protein than cows for instance XO
protein was created by a three
michelin-starred chef and two Ivy League
grads they have made a line of protein
bars that will I think really blow your
mind and some of my friends were
journalists to V then tested them with
glucose monitors to see what the glucose
response is because they have a little
bit of carbs in them and it was flatline
provoked no huge glucose or insulin
response whatsoever so there you go you
have that they combined the cricket
protein with simple ingredients like
cocoa almond butter and so on to create
a bar that takes just about every box
you could possibly care about their
paleo gluten free soy free dairy free
low glycemic no refined sugar the list
goes on
they are my go to bars and for all of
you guys listening EXO is offering a
sampler pack of their four most popular
flavors for less than $10 Wow
supplies last and that's not an
infomercial while supplies last the last
time they were on the podcast this sold
out in about a week so I recommend you
check it out their startup very limited
supplies go to XO protein com EXO PR OT
ein comport / Tim and you can be one of
the first to try the future of protein
so check it out EXO protein comm forward
slash Tim this podcast is brought to you
by 4 Sigma tech I reached out to these
Finnish folks young entrepreneurs very
talented after a Acrobat introduced me
to one of their products which is
mushroom coffee this specific one
includes chaga and lion's mane and knock
my socks off I highly recommend if you
try it you start with half a packet it's
very strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer I try to force
this on all of my houseguests it is a
hell of a thing I have employees or
people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect and gets a lot more out
of them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI GM a tea ice
komm forward slash tim and use the code
tim TI m to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive
anyway if you are in the experimental
mindset I do not think you'll be
disappointed to try them why hello boys
and girls this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
whether they are entertainers like Jamie
Foxx military like general stem from a
crystal or Jacko willing chess prodigies
like Josh Waitzkin or everybody and
anyone in between who is the best of
what they do in this episode is no
different it is a bit of a hybrid I am
interviewing it the master illusionist
and endurance artist you have asked for
four years David Blaine and it is a
really fun conversation at least I had a
blast and it is composed of outtakes
what does that mean well these are bits
and pieces I'd say about 90% of it is
from a TV show that I found and we
filmed for three hours and it got cut
down to an hour-long TV episode and you
can see this episode on a TV show called
fearless and you can see the entire
episode which does not really overlap
with this audio at att.net forward slash
fearless and I highly recommend that you
check it out people have been really
buzzing about it and this is all extras
so you will hear all sorts of stories
and bonus bits that didn't make it in we
jump around quite a lot to various
conversations stories and lessons with
David and the very first conversation
begins with the two of us talking about
my second book the 4-hour body and
learning to hold my breath which he
taught me at the TEDMED conference ages
ago and I went from a max press hold of
45 seconds to three minutes and 30
seconds or slightly longer so I am going
to try to keep this somewhat short but
two things number one I would love for
you to check out the TV show the entire
season is filmed and you can find out
where you can see all of the episodes at
Blagh forward slash fearless that's tim
dot blog for slash fearless that has
trailers all the guests everything else
and if you want to see the entire first
episode at least for a short period of
time with david blaine just go to
att.net forward slash fearless and there
are some issues it seems viewing it with
Chrome's and try Safari or Firefox or
something else and that is it so I hope
you enjoy this conversation and
experience as much as I did please say
hi to David on the socials he's easy to
find Blaine VLA I and II he does not
disappoint thank you welcome to fearless
I'm your host Kim Barris and on this
stage will be deconstructing world-class
performers of all different types
uncover the specific tactics and
strategies they've used overcome doubt
tackle their hardest decisions and
ultimately succeed on their own terms so
let's take a look at my guest by the
numbers 17 minutes four seconds his
world record-setting breath hold if you
can believe that it's true 44 days how
long you survive without food in a
plexiglass box 63 hours 42 minutes and
15 seconds the amount of time he spent
encased in a block of ice for nearly 20
years he has risked his life for your
entertainment please welcome to the
stage world-renowned illusionist and
endurance artist David Blaine
yep you wrote about it in your book I
did which I was super excited about yeah
the second edition of the toilet I had
to pull it okay so let me explain what
happened it turns out that I guess if
you have an audience of X number of
people let's say it's a million people
one out of every thousand is not going
to read directions it turns up so I had
people who just weren't reading the
warnings but what made me want to put it
in the books so badly is that it takes
this impossible I can't do X and just
obliterate oh yeah then I remember I
think it's very next time that I met you
after that and I paid a lot of attention
to your performances but then I started
tracking you a lot more closely not like
a stalker creepy way but in a very
diligent fan way and we met at I don't
even ever where was might have been at
one of these summit events in DC but I
sat down I noticed you had a tattoo on
yeah he's on the inside your voice yeah
so yesterday numbers here what are those
numbers it's primo Levy's Paulo close
numbers and he's he was one of my
favorite writers because even though he
went through such a terrible and
horrific experience he wrote about it
without any bias actually it's almost
like he recorded it with a video camera
and just documented what he went through
and the concentration camp and because
he was a chemist he didn't look at you
know you are different than me or this
not to use different than this too we
looked at everybody is biological
compositions of molecule you know
everything is just a part of life so
therefore he just studied humanity it's
one of its most atrocious incidents and
he would say thing he would write things
that you wouldn't by the way he started
to write this book as soon as he got out
his arm was barking he immediately you
know he was able to write he immediately
began to write and people didn't believe
him and you know because a lot of people
thought the Holocaust was still made up
at that time and he would say things
that because he was a chemist so before
he went to Auschwitz he was a great
chemist and a paint factory is where he
worked but
he would observe what certain people did
to survive so he explained like you had
to sleep with your head here your feet
here your head here your you know packed
like sardines basically and he would
explain that somebody that might survive
would be the the guy laying in the bunk
at night they could listen to the level
of the latrines the latrines were being
you know before the toilets in the
middle of the bunk and when you would
hear the latrine was filled to the top
if you were able to sleep just enough
but stay awake enough that you could
listen when it was full to the top you'd
say to the two people to your side if
you have to go to the bathroom don't go
now and he would say that because he
would listen to the level of the
latrines know how full it was and then
if they would have to go to the bathroom
then they'd have to go empty at two
miles away and while walking they would
spill the urine and the crap all over
their feet and so when they came back
and and you had to sleep with your head
next to it you'd get sick and when you
get sick and I camp your kill you're
done so it was like he would explain
things that you'd never think about and
then when he became a very respected
writer like Philip Roth and Italo
Calvino all these guys say he's one of
the most important nonfiction writers of
all time but he went back to working in
the paint factory he never moved out of
the apartment Reno Italy that he grew up
on he never travelled for luxury he was
a really impressive and interesting
first well I remember asking you what
you learned from the book because I know
just the tattoo then you mentioned the
book I said would you learn you said
everything I'm like well I think I need
to buy a book so I went out and I bought
if this is a man and the truth behind
those are made and I have to tell you
guys you want to talk about beautiful
insightful writing I think it highlights
in that book alone or the next ten
combined on my shelf I still have it
facing out on my bookshelf of my living
yes I'm a minor and after you read it
when you open your refrigerator you're
you're never going to think about food
or anything the same weight is there but
wow I'm so lucky it's kind of like the
stoic philosophers like Marcus really so
these people they use negative
visualization and what they do with that
is they imagine the worst possible
scenario so let's say somebody has a
daughter he's going to imagine that
tomorrow his daughter might die and he
might not see her ever again
so therefore the time that he's with his
daughter he's going to be very connected
to her he's not going to be looking
through his iPhone or watching TV he's
going to be paying full attention to her
which is I think an amazing point of
view where is the father that assumes oh
my daughter's going to outlive me and
she'll be here forever when they're
together he might be sitting there
staring at the TV or reading the
newspaper and not really giving her the
full attention so and it's also the same
the way he thinks about like a glass of
water so think like instead of saying
like oh this glass is half-empty but Wow
lucky that have water not just my lucky
that water but I have it in a glass it
actually will hold it and I'm not going
to get lead poisoning from this glass
it's going to be clean and taste good so
it's like that that's that's kind of
what I learned from training Olivia and
I've been on top of that you just
mentioned the stones which is one of my
favorite topics I'll not talk about the
next like seven hours to save you guys
but the fact that debuted as practice it
was it was trainable mm-hmm so it was a
regular practice I mean you have one
hell of a collection of what most people
would consider pretty strange practices
I want to talk about cold for a second
so if this is correctly this is not
accurate but I I know
Laird Hamilton and those guys Laird is
the undisputed king a big wave surfing
and he's married to Gabby Reece who's
equally impressed very amazing Hiller
married volleyball player amazing
parents and they have these workouts at
their house in in Southern California in
this neck of the woods and they have a
custom pool with stairs that go down to
the bottom and people do weight training
underwater among other things and then
they have an ice bath which is they
realize that you get in and you have to
wedge yourself through the ice over the
ice bath and a sauna 220 degrees and
they cycle through all three of these I
remember at one point somebody I want to
his workout said oh man you should have
been here last week wim HOF was here wim
HOF he was called the ice man he's this
Dutch daredevil he has 20-something
World Records for his incredible ice
exposures they considered ice bath like
two hours
finer to climb my first year we climbed
up a deaf altitude at Everest in boots
and shorts nothing else
pretty impressive guy on a lot of levels
of Records when my undereyes yeah you
swam under ice until his retina froze i
mean--the article not recommended by the
way no matter how good your eyesight
might seem so I was told that you guys
started trading ideas and then started
doing all sorts of wacky stuff is that
what happened oh yeah yeah we had fun he
did but I had actually never tried
holding my breath underwater and ice
which I you know I could I could resist
really cold temperatures for a pretty
good amount of time but I didn't I
always thought okay so when I first
tried to learn how to hold my breath I
actually read about the boy that fell
under the icy River and he was trapped
for 45 minutes he blacked out they
pulled him up and he was brought to full
recovery so my initial thinking was okay
if I put myself in a really in an ice
bath and I dropped my core temperature
then I'll be able to hold my breath long
but it was before I really learned the
technique so I got in this ice bag
shivering and then I tried to do the
breath holding it was you know as a bus
yeah but that was years ago but then
when I hung out with him he was like
let's let's try it let's let's try it
this way and I did it his way under the
ice bath and it was incredible yeah what
was his trick was it the breathing
beforehand or did you suppose you know
what it is here's what it is it when you
see somebody else do it right it's like
you suddenly realize oh wait there's a
way to do this but then you can push
yourself to do things that you don't
think are possible because you've seen
somebody else do it well it's like you
in the breath holding and then suddenly
on they're doing the breath holding and
I remember at one point interviewing
Robert Rodriguez enough you guys know
director writer everything
extraordinaire and he studies artists
you love studying artist and he found
this artist a German artist and he
wanted to figure out how he did is to
fake so you flew all the way over to
Europe sat down and asked the guy to
give him a lesson so the guys doing this
is miss like a - I'm a Chinna - on the
nose and he goes how do you know which
one is next is what Robert has Tomatoes
you don't it's different every time it
Roberts like what the hell I flew all
the way in here and this is my left are
you kidding me and then he sat down he
tried it and he could do it just because
he saw someone do it
Wow and it was possible now in his
subconscious mind coming out of his own
way so we talked about ice
I want to flip that and talk about fire
so we're going to rewind the clock did
you have one or multiple homes burned
out yes as a kid I had a three three
fires in the buildings I lived in so but
I mean obviously we got out but two of
them I didn't even wake up my mother
carried me out run down the stairs and I
didn't see any of it I just found out
the next day but it lose your did you
lose your stuff work yeah and that's why
I have so few pictures and stuff like
that for my childhood is from those
fires I see yeah because we have a
handful of photos but I have a very
limited collection of photos did you did
that affect how you relate to material
possessions all or no my mother never
really placed high value on material
possessions I think she taught me that
yeah she tell you before the fire yeah
so we talked a little bit about
potentially using coal to hold your
breath for longer and then you mentioned
faster well wait but you hold doesn't it
doesn't help you hold it longer but it's
just an interesting concept that you can
hold your breath while your trees should
be fasting I also read Kafka The Hunger
artist and in the Hunger artist guy is a
dime circus performer and nobody wants
to see him and he does his show the
buddy of your shows up so he decides
he's gonna sit in a little cage and he's
going to go I think for a month or no
month and a half without food no forty
days I think without food and he gets in
this little cage and he starts fasting
and people start to come and then as he
starts fasting so to get skinny skinny
seasons and crowd starts becoming at the
end of the kafka story there's tons of
people there but he's got he's just
rivalled away to the lake it is a no
good food but it was you know Kafka
explains the whole curve of doing one of
those things in a really poetic and
interesting way so I think that plus the
curiosity plus you just love like though
you kind of your brain changes because
you're not thinking about you know
you're like we spend a lot of time
during our day planning our next
miel like what am I going to later am I
going now with my Guinea tonight and
when you take that away because because
well you know Bria we are able to go a
long time I don't recommend it but you I
think we can go very long time about
food and when you take that away it's
like your brain starts to see things in
a really beautiful way actually we have
a mutual friend
fantastic stand-up comedian and actor
native Brian Cowen we'll come back to
Brian but one of his questions was you
know or suggested topics to explore was
suffering because you correct along you
grew up you had asthma yeah and and
recently I found out but I have my my
right coronary artery I've never said
this anybody but it takes in a regular
path between my eye Horta my I order my
pulmonary artery so it's getting
stenosis 50% stenosis so my heart gets
basically 50% of the blood flow that you
get or anybody gets so if it's very
dangerous obviously but at the same time
I think that might be why I'm able to
hold my breath for such an extended
period of time
before I started training if you were to
describe say how you interacted with
other kids teachers or otherwise I'll be
like I was hyperactive or weirdo but I
did not that's not why we're here today
so I'm not gonna talk about that but I'm
glad there's we didn't have as much
medication I would have been drugged out
of my mind
nothing yeah we got a lot not gonna go
down the drug at Hellfest kidding ah
yeah how are you is good I mean I was
definitely not hyperactive you know I
was like your polar opposite us but but
I'm I think I was kind of similar I was
very curious I love magic I love
learning I loved reading I had to build
a lot of you know walls really quick in
Brooklyn in the late 70s it was it's a
tough it was a tough environment back
then so I learned how to defend myself I
would take the subway
to school when I was five or six I was
much more mature probably as a kid than
now so health of the kid that that would
get you know really good grades but then
the teacher would mark class clown
parent-teacher conference needed my mom
commands I don't get it why this gives
me great was you have to a lot of yet
and he's like well he's he's a bit of a
clown I guess I was a crazy kid now I
read correctly some wrong head you trade
punches with kids and like walk to
school in arts nowhere yeah did I I
talked about them somewhere I guess you
must have yeah yeah yeah how did you
decide to do any of that
well know that hold on so the barefoot
in the snow running yep I had a karate
teacher also the YMCA named Prince and
he and he for some reason he just like
me well or didn't let nobody like me so
he would run barefoot through the snow
and I would just do it with him and then
I started doing things like that on my
own
and then I would go all winter which was
t-shirts on and I kind of liked enduring
it you know yeah so that what led to
that I'm just so curious I mean I I had
a couple of weird things that I would do
just to see if I could endure it I mean
I was out of the rut in school so the
only sport I ended up being able to play
with any success wrestling's his weight
quest is but I just got my ass kicked up
until like sixth grade so I did weird
coping things to try to cut down on
bullying so like put my hand in fact
that was gonna put my hands flat on
table don't do this at home and just let
people hit the hand or I'll do the alien
fear like Bishop move and people like
okay I can kick his ass but he's just
crazy enough that I'm gonna go after an
easy target right so but what led to the
the enduring of the cold like you
remember deciding to do that or was it
just after Prince's influence well no
now that I think about it but
technically speaking my mother got
remarried when I was about 10 years old
we moved to New Jersey and and her
husband was always worried about you
know sick things like that so he would
always
you know layered up I think part of like
my rebellion against having to follow
any specific directions was the CDIP I
go around all I went through the future
[Laughter]
will definitely come back to your mom
because she's such a critical and
influential piece of a puzzle but it
won't reduce you to chess my mother had
a boyfriend at the time who's now my
godfather and he taught me chess when I
was really young and I think my
biological father might have also but I
don't know because I didn't see him much
how you drawn to magic and the chest was
sort of a thinking if you're a master of
misdirection I mean and we could
certainly talk about that but that's a
similar did that develop there too that
come later what I mean I you know a deck
of cards has so many different you know
you can shuffle it back and the odds of
shuffling it in the same order you could
have them you know the trillion people
shuffling cards for years and years and
years and you'll never match the same or
insight so I think there are so many
algorithms and mathematical features
built into cards and as a magician
that's that's what you use in the
beginning so it's like the first tricks
I started doing with cards were simple
mathematical tricks and my mother would
go crazy and so I started to really want
to learn different things and I started
working on and I think that was the love
of math I think the love of science
logic chess I think it's all all girl
right yeah and when did it become did it
just gather steam steadily from there
were there particular inflection points
for you I think I just kept working on
it and working on and still working on
it the same way it's just a non-stop
learning new things and trying things
and becoming obsessed and yeah it's
important helps
you learn a lot in the environment you
learn so much about performance because
you learn and I guess it's related to
salesmanship almost like you learn if
you're too close to the people that are
sitting down and you walk ups and you
want to do magic they're too close
you're kind of like they're like Oh
hating your principles right or but if
you're too far away they kind of will
throw you away very easily so there's
like that balance point that you learn
of how close you need to be to the table
who to approach first you do the magic
then they're engaged and you have them
and you know I think there's some what
psychology applied to that I want to ask
about taking the right person at the
table so you walk into a restaurant
figured out kind of the personal space
you figured out how to befriend the
Alfa's in jail and then you get
everybody else
I like chimpanzee a holiday killer or so
when you go to a table in a restaurant
you said picking the right person how do
you pick the right person it's so hard
to explain like a spider sense yeah it's
like after you do it a thousand times
and you get rejected enough times you
start to learn if it's amazing to hurt a
rumor it's not scandalous don't worry
that when you're working as a waiter at
some point you would give you tips you'd
give the tips back here and not you an
area of the money that why you did your
research now yeah it was good yeah that
is it okay yeah would do I would do
magic but just because I'd like to do
the magic so they would often leave I
was working at a health food restaurant
in New York but back then and like 91
there wasn't it was the only one it was
called sue nth and I would do magic to
the people and they would leave me like
50% to 100% double the bill in tip and I
would give it back to them I would say
just give me 20% because I've been do
magic for that but just come back and so
they would all come back and they became
you know regulars at the rest of it yet
i I just didn't I didn't want people to
think that like oh this is for this
which it was
the book that blows me away beyond
anything and it's hard to explain it
Cervantes Cervantes yeah and that guy
his life he wrote Don Quixote and his
life was the most thing for a writer his
life is what writers dream for even
though it was a horrific and terrible
life so Cervantes was the son of a
surgeon in Spain and we he died in 1616
the same year Shakespeare but back then
you were very poor so when he was I
think 18 or something he joined the
military to fight for his country he got
shot and was maimed on the left sides
was paralyzed on his left arm but he won
the equivalent of the Purple Heart so
the king gave him a letter on their trip
back home in the boat
pirates basically took them captive he
was made into a slave for five years and
while they were trying to get ransom
because he had this letter from the king
so they thought he was so important and
so wealthy which he wasn't they would
just abuse and torture him finally his
brother got the monks to raise enough
money five years later so he went back
home and the only job that he could get
was as a tax collector right the
government giving him this job but
because that guy had such a big heart
you didn't want to take taxes or mother
with five babies who couldn't feed them
so he wouldn't do his job the way the
government want to so they put him in
prison and he spent 12 years in prison
among prison he started writing Don
Quixote he finished it when he got out
and it became the number one bestseller
in Europe it was one of the most
respected books Shakespeare wrote an
entire play about one character that was
burned in the fire cook about gardenia
but even with all the success of
publisher screwed him over so he never
saw a penny so Cervantes died completely
broke and he's one of the greatest most
influential writers to this day but when
you read the book it makes sense because
the characters about a guy that wants to
make the world a better place needs
delusional because there's no way it's
very difficult to do that so he's you
know fighting windmills and imitating
life like anything I hear but yeah how
many times do you read that book I
always an incredible recap well that's
their like that's not
well Arthur book is not oh my god
the book is even crazier all right it's
I I try not to read it when I'm on an
airplane because if there's people
sitting next to me it's like when I'm on
one page I'm like laughing hysterically
and then I'm crying but I'm laughing
hysterically so I seem like a roaster
you know real quick and look you're bad
but if that book is incredible as a kid
did you feel like a loner or lonely or
did you feel something else and this
seems like a lot on your own in this
Curia I feel most of my friends are
better magicians are usually not of the
norms the issues we don't necessarily
fit in in the note you know in the
typical way so there is a lot of time
spent alone but that time spent alone is
when you learn how to do these things
that we would never do if you were out
having fun with you know so it's like
you're working on one move repetitiously
for hours on end for days and weeks and
months years yeah there is a lot of time
that you spend isolated so you get into
magic around 5:00 at what point at what
age did your mom pass away she got sick
when I was uh 17 years old and she
fought for a couple of years and died
three years later and and it was a very
ambitious fight and struggle she tried
to overcome it and did everything in our
power from the macrobiotic diet to you
know acupuncture and just Chinese
medicine just everything plus the normal
route and the doctors gave her I believe
six months to live at one point and she
did it was called Michio Kushi rotor he
was called me too because she wrote a
book called the macrobiotic way and
basically what she did she eliminated
all excess from her diet and just ate
food that was rich in micronutrients and
had all the things that are necessary
and what happened was a tumor started to
disappear because she started to I guess
when you don't have excess enough fat
you're just getting the micro nutrition
they need she started to probably digest
her
whatever the tumor starts dissipating
sift out and she actually was on the
road to beating the cancer and then and
then I guess when she did go into
remission she started to eat you know
that the normal foods and then came back
really fast and we think used to tell me
you know that you know when I do this by
when I eat in a bill that then kale
wasn't the popular things at scale and
seaweed and all these different things
she's she told me that you know the the
way the Chinese do what their hair is
black for a very long time they don't go
gray and she went from gray to full
color back at one point so doing all
that ice
I saw it did so many amazing changes
take place and her approach and her and
her belief that you know and I'm sure
part of his mental that she could be
that was until recently when I had a
daughter but it was like it was because
that loss was so overwhelming and so
like horrific that I never wanted to put
myself in that place agenda and right
yes it was really I was always very you
know difficult to get through
and as a five-year-old and it's it's a
it's the most of the most amazing
experience in my life and it's beyond
anything the words could ever explain
and she's doing magic but I think
teachers just they just watch you know
she just watches just watches and then
she starts doing it like oh I don't
whether to do magic cuz I don't want her
to do the crazy thing soon as I say not
as I do yeah that is an adult put the
ice pick you and I encourage the pan or
the singer Lita i teases me she's like
well I'm gonna do things too I'm gonna
stand I'm building like no you're not
that's not Jesus yeah yep yes I said
nope internal jambe in some cases the
apples does not fall far from the tree
they just observe yes they absorb
everything and I don't know how much is
just also a mate like you're somehow
programmed towards magic I really wonder
because I have a friend fantastic guy if
you haven't met me she'd be at some
point Josh Waitzkin so Josh Waitzkin was
the basis for searching for bobby
fisher' both the book and the movies he
was the little kid who's the chess
prodigy and he had a very tough time
being thrown into the public light and
with the movie as a 14 or 15 year old it
was very challenging for him and it
interfered with his chest career and so
on and so forth so she never he never
pulled that just whatever Wow
and at one point his son just found some
type of who's around the same age as uh
daughter uh an online chess program and
he just sat there for hours hours got
better and better and better and he's
just like well I guess it's complete
crazy won't ball yeah I be he saw maybe
he was somehow because my daughter uses
the iPad when she's allowed to shall
push the button and say she has a French
accent show me pictures of David Blaine
like all that spending like mellow right
there in the water and I Sunday but
maybe there's some sort of you know
maybe he saw something or he you know
but but who knows maybe it is just
intuitive there has to be and I know
because I've seen you work a room not
worker that sounds weird but seeing you
add a pile at a party let's just say and
you can navigate space really really
well and part of your story is so
incredible because like alright he was
in restaurants they did this and then he
saw this one person and did this trick
to them and then it led to this limit
led to that and so I want to bring up I
guess to two parts of that so one is do
you have aside from like the spider
sense is there anything else that helps
you to decide which people to engage
with insert in the situation like that
no because I kind of just do it to
everybody but yeah I talk a lot a lot of
year now I think I love doing it I just
like the process of billions I just do
it all the time
you know but you've been very good at
capitalizing on the opportunities that
have presented themselves and so one of
them that I wanted to get a little bit
backstory on to seems like a pivotal
moment and if it wasn't I want you to
tell me but going to saint-tropez
I guess it was yeah I was hired
by this amazing man is name was Jeffrey
Steiner and just a very powerful
self-made billionaire and we got the
part I was young it was like 19 or 20
maybe and I was doing magic at this bar
mitzvah I did magic to this man
he's very intrigued and he said have you
ever been this ental thing I said what
well I can never hurt I don't even know
what it is so I said no he said is my
code call me so you know I called him
and and he asked me to he asked me to
come to his office to meet with them but
he was going to have me you know
possibly come during the summer and work
and I remember sitting in his office in
the waiting rooms
it was so fancy and incredible and there
was a security guard standing in the
corner
and he was reading a newspaper I think a
newspaper stand there reading the paper
and I was just sitting there waiting I
was like 5 minutes 10 minutes waiting
and I look at the security guard like
excuse me and a guy does a budge excuse
me it wasn't bud so I walk up to and I
touch them and it was one of those like
Madame Tussaud wax I didn't even know
people had those types of things to the
garden either in the waiting room it was
amazing yeah as amazing no way then he
asked me to go and and and really the
learning lesson was watching how he you
know just the way he deals with
everybody the same I think there's no
judgments it doesn't judge me as as kid
or you know there's powerful everybody's
kind of treated in a very similar way
and very elegantly and very caring and
you know I kind of learned from him as
well that that really all people are the
same so it's not like you believe that
there's a divide because somebody's you
know rich powerful or present and I
quickly learn that and I was lucky to
learn at that point that all people are
the same not I mean obviously there's
differences
never each individual but I learned not
to judge on late to them I learned not
to judge somebody for any reason because
everybody ultimately is a human being so
that I mean I learned that also for my
mother but when you see it in a
different context it's a very valuable
if yeah it reinforces it so let's talk
about it I yet different context you
watch mr. Steiner interacting with
people and then had he bumped into Jack
Nichols well yeah it was there and yes
he was also one of my favorites
obviously and it was you know do magic
him and I end up it was I remember it
was like an unknown kid at the time and
I remember that it was in in this club
there and they turned the music off to
say tonight we have Jack Nicholson and
David blanking of Suffolk whoa that's
pretty crazy like suddenly I was like
known in that co-headline of Jack
Nichols yeah so if I could get for an
idea yes when I came back when I came
back to America so it was kind of like
you know that because I was around you
know Jack Nicholson people like that
once again I realized that you know it
would be possible to to create these
things I want to do because you meet
this guy Jack that you looked up to it
and he's incredible one of the best in
the world and you realize it but he's
also still just another person so that
it it's demystifying in a weird way but
it's also like it's incredible because
you realize that there is no it's not
it's like if you work hard and you
pursue something you can you can get
there if you just don't quit you're
relentless
so will you put in the reps to write how
many people do you think you'd
approached or demonstrated magic to you
before you hit never yeah I'm starting
as a kid yeah have it stand up on chairs
and perform when I was five in front of
people my mother's friends and random
strangers and stuff like that I forget
to just the time put in over and over
what is the approach some I'm curious I
read about I think you used to go out
with a friend named Adam his last name I
can't pronounce gig bought gig boy oh
yeah Adam given love god father to his
children yeah and I'm good okay guys
would oh yeah well he had that was about
that was early on he would crash into we
would sneak into different you know cool
events you know and Adam would just walk
up and and act like he was best friends
with everybody and say David's going to
do magic for you and then I would just
start doing magic to everybody and it
was yeah it was like back then that yeah
I think people started writing stories
as a guy named AJ Benza who's with the
Daily News so I met through Mickey
Rourke back there and he he basically
you know he kind of like started putting
me out there just writing though so
David did this to this person that
person how did he pick up on that
because you did magic to him or did you
just start hearing about it's really
great fun I think like back then I think
it was just New York same thing this is
the novelty here new on the sand yeah
and also magic wasn't not everybody was
rare it was rare to come across a
magician back then there was a little
group of magicians that hung out nedeli
called Rubens on Madison Avenue in New
York every Saturday and it was like this
little dirty back room of a coffee shop
and we would just sit there and
brainstorm ideas and the most incredible
magicians from all over the world would
just show up and walk in and blow
everybody's minds and then I would you
know engage my favorite ones and
convinced them to teach me one thing and
that you know that was a what were some
of the things you picked up from Rubens
you think back to any America there
lessons or any particular moment that
blew your mind like yeah I mean there's
so many there are so many different
moments there was a guy named Frank
Garcia who was an amazing magician
I was really gone he said to me said one
day all the magicians are going to be
really mad at you
they were they're going to be jealous of
you I'm going to tell you right now
because you're going to do things that
are just going to drive them up so when
I did do that I didn't I didn't take it
first what he did his rattle he told you
is coming right he predicted it and no
but I met magicians they're like one of
my best friends and basically my brother
at this point bill Kalusha was this
incredible technician but he didn't do
magic so he could impress people he
didn't do magic to perform he would just
sit there alone day and night and just
practice moves for himself and he's
phenomenal like one of the best in the
world and so I say to him so would you
be do the magic to me and go holy how
did I do
but it's no but for him it's almost like
he has yeah it's like it's like a paint
versus like a painter paints because he
needs to express something so he plays
with cards because he needs to express
something or just work something out and
digital fixation or something like that
you don't have Adam as your wingman you
just called approaches celebrity what do
you how do you make it happen I think
when we do when I do magic it's pretty
much the same thing it's just kind of
like would you would you just walk up
and down one phase okay I'm just rolling
it varies you know have you could you
been intimidated to approach anybody
come to mind or if the answer is nobody
you know speaking you know act actually
but one of the people I did speak to on
the phone for the end of his life for
for quite a while I spent maybe two
years on an author was Bobby Fischer no
kidding yeah I I pursued him the girl
that was working for me Denise Albert
knew something what motive a Miss
Jessica layers of all time there the
movie searching for bobby fischer's and
but anyway this woman Denise Albert that
was working for me who's amazing at just
getting through that anything or anybody
tracked him down and Iceland founds me
that tried to get an interview with and
the son
got a message I wanted to talk to him
somehow we start speaking and and then
we started talking but and then we start
talking all the time by everything
amazing stories and history and chess
stories and actually have some of that
like a friend here one time but that was
one of the people I was most intrigued
by by one of the yes Michaelis booze I
liked the most excited to get to he was
one of them the other guy that was that
I would love to meet is this
mathematician named Grigori Perelman
Grigori Perelman he lives outside of st.
Petersburg I believe and he solved one
of the most difficult conundrums of the
last century and they offered him a
million-dollar prize which he refused
because when he gave the solution
basically it took all the other
mathematicians twelve years to even
realize that he was right so he was so
disappointed in mathematicians that he
was like forget this they quit doing
that
tearing the prize down and went moved
back in with his mother and they said he
and he lives in this like this little
apartment they say his mattress is on
the floor he's almost like cockroach
infested and so the Guardian tried to
reach him in an interview and when the
Guardian got through and they're like
why did you refuse a million dollars
he said please don't bother me I'm busy
picking mushrooms so that's a guys love
your kind of guy is loyal really honest
I think I'd have to like stay in front
of his house for a couple of weeks and
son I don't even know how
there was an old trick where you know
you would it's called a needle through
arm and I've seen magician to do where
they pretend to push it through their
arm and it bleeds and stuff like that
when I started thinking well wait there
must be a way to do something similar
but in a more magical way but actually
do it and then I started working on you
know what points in the body could you
do it the craziest one is a guy named
Miren died Oh from he used to take rape
years and he'd have them push straight
through his body like to his lungs and
then he would go jogging with the things
that uh nobody believed him so heard
through the bodies and enough nobody
believed them so time life finally
covered him and in front of you know all
the doctors and scientists which they
think no there's no way this could be
possible because we know that when a
sword a rapier goes through you're going
to die he was just able to do it over
and over like nothing to have it pushed
through
he'd go jogging and he would pull it out
there was nothing but then he started to
get really cocky he started to think he
was invincible so he decided that he was
going to drink a swallow like one of
those big sailing needles he swallowed
this this big sailing needle and then he
was going to push it through a stomach
but he couldn't get it out he fell
asleep and it ruptured his I Ord and he
bled out and died yeah no selling
needles the audience all right what
would be the one piece of advice you
would give your 25 year old self and if
you could tell us at 25 where you are
and what you're doing
roughly I would say to enjoy where you
are because you're always trying to
think ahead and plan ahead and I was
always you know as young producing my
first TV show and working so diligently
to try to get to a place that you never
ever get to because they're always
trying to get to another place of a good
thing to do is to just sit back and kind
of you know
breathe in and be like wow this is
pretty awesome good because you don't it
was rare that I you never stop and just
appreciate the the now have you become
better at that no I wasn't planning on
going and dressed but I'll tell you so
in college actually what six days that's
it and I did it because I was studying
neuroscience time and we used well there
are a number of labs that used cats they
studied cats because they sleep so off
so you could really look at their REM
sleep cycles and serotonin was one of
the neurotransmitters they could look
into that it came very fascinated by
we're going to get out there for a
second folks the similarities between
and I had never used at this point but
LSD induced experiences and REM sleep
and I wondered how if I completely I
wondered what would happen if I
completely deprived myself of REM sleep
hence the experiment wasn't fantastic I
called it to a close because I was
walking to class and just effectively
blacked out like my mind went blank and
then I woke up about two hundred steps
later after I crossed the street and I
was like yeah I think I need to stop
doing this right now but I am fascinated
by sleep deprivation particularly the
Vision Quest version of that so you
didn't get any of those visions as well
I did I did have not not the good kind
or productive kind I
what ended up happening is things would
jump out I'd see flashes of rapid
movement in my peripheral vision which
was really terrifying yeah
and that was the most common sight
seeing jerking motion right in my
peripheral vision so I haven't done too
much of that recently but I am
interested in things like modafinil just
studying that by the way folks
if someone says there no side effects of
a given drug that's just because they
haven't found them yet no give it time
there's a short story by David Sedaris
called naked and it's hilarious know it
the book is called naked the short story
is called plague of ticks and it's
amazing it's about this just this kid
that has all these insane ticks if you
just can't stop and it's a great story
about what we're talking about play mint
plague is ticks like the tick now they
grew up with them around they're like oh
my gosh but that's my nightmare
so you've tasted eros at the same time
yeah this is one of my favorites magic
is all about capturing or diverting
attention what are some basic tactical
ways to divert someone's attention for
the purpose of performing simple magic
tricks I think just really communicating
with somebody because if you're really
talking to somebody that they're gonna
look here I mean but then again the
magic that I like the most stuff that
you don't need people to look away so I
would work on things that it doesn't
matter who's looking at what for the
most part so if you're not trying to
divert let's just say in some of your
early environments which like you said
we're not ideal environments loud clubs
people yelling how do you be what are
some good ways to get someone's
attention you have to adjust the magic
to the environment so depends on the
circumstance yeah
or when you try to learn always learning
but what I'm currently reading is
American Prometheus about Oppenheimer
and this is one of the more fascinating
men that I've read about he created the
atomic bomb and it was a race between
Japan Germany and America so he
developed this weapon and it basically
stopped Japan or Germany from having an
atomic bomb which who knows what they
would have done I mean to the world to
this day and after he created it was
used he realized he created the ultimate
weapon of death and it's horrible it's
the worst thing that you could ever do
and this is guy to grow up with poetry
and art and studying Picasso and he
started being very vocal about how awful
this weapon of mass destruction was and
Hoover had just become president and
Hoover was very Pro militaria Pro
weapons Pro building better bombs and
they went after him in a witch hunt and
destroyed him destroyed up and I'm they
like Galilei like just took everything
away from embarrassed him shamed him
ISIL everything that you could imagine
but he was in court and they asked him
in court they said how many people would
it take to sneak an atomic bomb into New
York and his answer was three just three
people that are willing to take that
risk okay how would you find that bomb
and he said with a screwdriver because
you have to open every single nut and
bolt in the city to protect it because
there's no way to so the idea of that
you know that anybody could take a dirty
bomb put it in any city and there's
nothing that could be done about that I
think you know that that's something
that's I think a real real
it human issue suddenly that's that's
what I've learned recently it's just
that I don't know how it relates to no
no this this actually leads me to ask it
seems like almost all the books that
we've or that you've talked about so far
have a component of tragedy what
Cervantes look at this the Primo levy
like there's some element of tragedy or
suffering in these books is that just
countenance of business books that came
up or you tend to pick books have that
element one of my favorite books is
man's search for meaning and at the end
of that book he says since outlets we
know what man is capable of and since
Hiroshima we know it's at stake so I've
been obsessed with and they say you know
one of the TED talks I love is about
what happens if a dirty bomb goes off
you're safe he says it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of when so it's like I
do think we're at a critical time where
we need to really you know analyze why
there are so many weapons of mass
destruction why they're trying to make
bigger ones again anyway he knows it so
I think that's a real concern and I'd
like to read about these things because
I do think it's important to think about
these things and then address them on
some level I guess I don't know thought
for sure I mean I'll say you look at say
like electromagnetic pulse weapons and
like the Great Lakes area knocking out
to engage in Chicago means is also one
of those questions is probably when not
if I don't really pleasant topic kind of
topics to talk about but to maybe focus
one
if you had you gave a fantastic TED talk
if you had to give a TED talk on
something that you're not known for at
all like some other obsession that you
have that maybe people don't know about
would you give it up
wow that's a great question what the
hell would I talk about something I
don't know about that seems so scary or
something you know about that people
don't you know the reason you know the
reason people are horrified of giving
speeches in public
lyza so I was reading the book of public
speaking I forget by who
and he said basically when you're
standing on a stage with lots of
eyeballs looking at you goes back a
million years if you were in Africa and
you were living in a protected let's say
a cave or shelter of some sort when you
want when you went out into an open
field or a plateau and suddenly there
were lots of eyes on you you have to be
worried because those were predators
that we're going to eat you so it's like
when you're standing basically exposed
where everybody can see you you're
suddenly an open target so your wiring
if your brain is I don't want to stand
up here with everybody staring at me
because it's counterintuitive to what
we've learned to survive over the last
you know 1.5 million years or even
longer whatever you know whatever it is
so that's reason so if I had to give a
public talk about something I didn't
know about I would talk into TED
Conference about my favorite food with
what you very well there's a pizza shop
in Brooklyn actually I give it see no no
no it's called the forest and the guy
has made over a million and a half
pizzas to me he's an artist
and it looks like a soup kitchen and
when you go in there it's like that
everything is kind of like messy
nothing's fancy and there's like these
things that his kids stuck on the wall
and they're like crooked and sideways
and it's like refuse that he's got more
the New York Times puts him on the cover
and so this isn't pizza this is art or
it's a cover of time out saying he's
most underrated
being in New York yes it's like all
these amazing views and when you go
there the guy he's made over a million
and a half pizzas he's been
doing it for 50 some years and his hands
look like polar bear Hannah no no
because he's reached into that oven so
many times and pulled out pizzas bear
barehanded that you that you couldn't
even eat for five minutes because it's
too hot and the guy just loves doing
what he does he's a perfectionist he
won't sell out you won't go do it
anywhere else he stays with this little
[ __ ] so you know fascinated with people
like that you know people that just get
so obsessed with their thing and want to
do it right and they're not in it for
the profit or making money he's just in
it for the love of make the greatest
Fiza so it's like the reasons i
fluctuate I stay away for the I think
that'd be a good test shock ya know but
I'd like to talking about people that
are so amazing what they do that just
have this passion that have done he's
like he basically that the mozzarella is
fresh the the Basil's Israel it grows at
this garden sometimes and he has like
all these incredible rich ingredients
and when the when the dough is out the
shop is closed you don't know if it's
going to be open when you get there but
you do get there there's a huge line
it's just gonna forest it's amazing I'll
be in your axilla or ever study IFA RA
got a forest peds advice I thought I
don't know how that would be a TED talk
maybe totally do a TED talk on that I
looking for a metaphor you talking about
pizza
you have a quote you're using a very
good memory for what you've read this
doesn't have to be from something you've
read to give a quote that you live by
think of Austin or any quotes you were
before talking about quotes from
Siddhartha you were saying I can fast I
can but he also says love is stronger
than hate soft is stronger than hard
water is stronger than stone so those I
think that's how it goes I think that
that's that's that's one of my favorite
pieces of that book
I like the Abraham Lincoln quote when I
do good I feel good when I do bad I feel
bad and that's my religion you know that
back quote I like there's so many one of
my favorites is Michelangelo says beauty
is the purgation of superfluities and
basically when he made the day that they
asked him how did you make this
beautiful thing out of that slab of
marble and he said well the beauty was
inside I just had to cut away all the
the crap basically some beauties of
purgation of superfluities I remember I
had to look up all the words so that I
can't read avoid if you were say
teaching a ninth grade class or freshman
class of college and you teach anything
what would you teach
I guess magic that makes perfect sense
ah moving on yeah that was right that's
that's a good that's that's the right
answer
can you think if you look back on your
life your career you can answer it
either these do you have a favorite
failure of yours okay or a failure that
actually really sowed the seeds of a
later success well that's the other
quote that I love as a Churchill quote
where he says success is the ability to
move from one failure to another with
enthusiasts but I look at everything I
never look at anything releases success
always look it is it's a work a work in
progress I'm always trying to figure out
how that so you so I don't see it as a
failure necessarily I see this practice
and work in progress but
so therefore then everything is not
right until it's right which means it's
never going to be right everything
technically is kind of a failure of it
but not really so I mean I don't look at
failure as a bad thing at all yes I'm
lucky with that I think how do you view
it and he said it's like work and then
no more failures the better you become
so it's like you know as long as you
don't die you know something like that
killing it but but no it's like it's all
a work in progress so I think failure is
like one of the best way building your
muscles like reading books is the best
way to build the brain is like working
out like the more you read the more the
brain starts to really absorb and mace
and think about new ideas and stuff like
that but seems it seems to me else when
I was reading primo Levy's books that as
a chemist he was trained to look at
things in a very experimental mindset it
was just feedback it was hypothesis test
feedback and so like you're mentioning
having a year for the training and just
picking up patterns like that and it
seems that it strikes me that you think
about failure in the way that a
scientist might think about I mean
you're testing a lot oh yeah probably
that's a good place to put an
exclamation as an exclamation point Pro
just a poetic period and what's what's
next we didn't bring that little tour
that I'm still gonna work out but
hopefully I'll eventually get it to feel
sort of right and then I'll start taking
it out across the country and through
the world and I'll try to build a magic
show that I would actually want to see
David Blaine you're amazing
guys give it up Dave Lynn
thank you guys hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
for me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday that provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy this
podcast is brought to you by 4 Sigma
tech I reached out to these Finnish
folks young entrepreneurs very talented
after a Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which is mushroom coffee
this specific one includes chaga and
lion's mane and it knocked my socks off
I highly recommend if you try it you
start with half a packet it's very
strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water
and oddly enough only includes 40
milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you'd get in a regular
cup of coffee I don't get any jitters as
reflux or any stomach burn any of that
it's very unusual and very very cool so
if you don't like caffeine they also
offer very strong but capping free
mushroom filters which I will sometimes
have in the evening I find chaga
specifically to be very very grounding
and earthy so that is another option and
I have a covered full of their products
at the moment which is right around the
corner my kitchen you can try something
you can try a sample path which is great
also right now by going for stick Matic
dot-com forward slash Tim that's for sig
Matic fo you are SI GM ATI si.com
forward slash Tim and use the code Tim T
IMD a 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I think
you'll be disappointed so try not this
episode's brought to you by XO protein
that's XO like the exoskeleton and
aliens and they make the only bars meal
replacement bars or pre-workout bars in
my case that I have in my house you can
hear the crinkling of cocoa nuts which
I'm going to get back to they're making
protein bars using cricket protein
powder and many of the CrossFit mutants
and high performers out there are eating
these I am also using them generally
pre-workout and I bet they taste better
than any protein bar you've ever had and
why is that just one of the benefits
while they are exceptionally high and
complete protein they are minimally
processed much less processed than most
say whey protein isolate and packed full
of nutrients including calcium omega-3s
and so on for those people are
interested also very sustainable soon as
part of the reason I ended up investing
in the company the United Nations
estimates that crickets are 20 times
more resource efficient per pound of
protein than cows for instance XO
protein was created by a three Michelin
star chef and two Ivy League grad they
have made a line of protein bars that
will I think really blow your mind and
some of my friends were journalists to
view them tested them with
glucose monitors to see what the glucose
responses because they have a little bit
of carbs in them and it was flatlined
for those no huge glucose point insulin
response whatsoever so there you go you
have that they combined the cricket
protein with simple ingredients like
cocoa almond butter and so on create a
bar that picks just about every box you
could possibly care about their paleo
gluten free soy free dairy free low
glycemic no refined sugar the list goes
on
they are my go-to bars and for all of
you guys listening EXO is offering a
sampler pack of their four most popular
flavors for less than $10 while supplies
last and that's not an infomercial while
supplies left the last time they're on
the podcast is sold out in about a week
so I recommend you check it out their
start up very limited supplies go to EXO
protein calm EXO PR OT CIN compost in
and you can be one of the first to try
the future of protein to check it out
EXO protein Escom forward slash 10
[Applause]